je devais démarrer tout de suite par la
boîte apoca partie des gens qui ont dit
les choses sur vous avant que je fasse
le conseil de classe de certains d'entre
vous parce que bon on sait de classement
d'appréciation mathieu roulent en
voitures de luxe mais demandent 50
centimes au chroniqueur pour payet le
café alors que le café coûte 30 centimes
les remparts alors la voiture du nuc
s'est prêté ou de desbiens je saute
annonce à nancy c'est un film censé
annoncer des prêts dans le smart brabus
ça c'est mon job et c'est vrai que
d'emprunter une fois 30 centimes à
benjamin que je lui rembourser sur le
champ non mais enfin c'est un oubli ça
n'oublie
alors voilà je sais c'est un oubli
attention alors on a aussi pour se
débarrasser de ses conquêtes à pain
battu encore mathieu leur demande
d'aller chercher le petit déj et ne leur
ouvre plus la porte ensuite qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire ça alors
c'est maintenant
racontez nous mais on nettoie hier j'ai
eu la chance bien ça doit vous
connaissez vous c'est le visage d'un
homme qui a fait l'amour ah ouais c'est
un homme barbara gould mais j'aime bien
les coïncidences terre en comptait hier
chez en voiture je m'arrête au feu ouais
un jeune garçon arrive en scooter
elle parle bien il ya un truc qui passe
un feeling momint la casse
on parle un petit peu et tout ça on va
prendre un verre j'ai un petit bonhomme
ouais bah je faisais pas l'émission hier
quoi vous le connaissiez pas non plus
très sympa mais alors ça ça arrive qu el
minzah moi j'aime les gens d'ailleurs
c'est bonnard et tout ça j'aime les gens
bon ton que c'était une bombe humaine
mais on a pris un verre un verre de jeu
c'était quoi votre excuse pour pas faire
l'émission hier alors général excuses du
tout je trouve que je ne suis pas
toujours convoqué l'émission il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont à faire la
productrice munich vous étiez convoqué
wade aviez dit que je viens prier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais jamais arrivé a très mal
j'écoutais cherchez pas je m'adonne
après bon bref c'est pas l'histoire on
se rencontre on prend un verre un
deuxième verre coup de botte dans le
coup de bol il habite pas loin
ouais on va s'asseoir ensemble non mais
arrêtez sur ma vie c'est une vraie
histoire et c'est vrai c'est vrai ouais
non mais faut que ça pète et chez lui
c'était chez moi donc chez vous c'est
quoi mais c'était chez huawei à bas à
bas le dorman en bas c'est un disque dur
un tas je te le demande et je ferai ce
cas d'abus des bons et donc donc voila
et laugnac
je demande au gardien ce qui se passe
dans cette fois c'est peu après
l'attaqué
pourquoi pas d'autorisation mais de quoi
ils l'ont bas du dangereux louvion
gibaud une motorisation ça va de
quelques indiens le pauvre son téléphone
sonnera permanent serait c'est vrai nom
il y aura des vérifications
quand j'ai passé une très belle soirée
et c'est vrai mais comment vous avez vu
ça ça caille des blés d'or ce matin leur
a coûté oui donc c'est un petit défaut
c'est qu'une fois que la chose est faite
au début je suis très bavard et je
m'intéresse aux opérations des gens
ressentent les choses est faible mais
reconnaît que la personne ma terrasse un
petit peu moins j'étais un petit peu à
les conduire pu rapidement non circuit
du mans mais vous verrez si un jour
votre appartement est très apprécié des
gens alors là c'est bon c'est bon train
je sais le poursuivre je pense que vous
allez déguerpir